[موسيقى]
احييكم مشاهدينا واهلا بكم الى نشره
360 طبعا الخبر من كل زواياه ومن جميع
جوانبه العناوين
اجتماع العشريني يتحول لقمه عن اوكرانيا
روسيا تصف الامر بالمهزله وبلينكن القاها
ليلافروف انهو عدوانكم
ايران انترناشونال ترصد بالوثائق زهران
فضغه لتحرير اموالها المجمده وبغداد ترفض
وتلتزم بضوابط واشنطن
هنا في مخيم الهول في الحسكه نسخه متجدده
عن تنظيم داعش اصغر ولكن جوله العربيه في
مخيمات الرعب قوانين داعش تحكم روج والهول
والنتيجه عشرات القتلى والمعذبين
في 360 لدينا ايضا
انقاد تركيا قد تغطي مئه كيلومتر مربع
وبالارتفاع متر وارزين تبقى لغزا صمدت بين
من هارا كل ما حولها
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم كما كان متوقعا تسببت الخلافات
في انهاء اجتماعات العشرين من دون التوصل
الى بيان ختامي مشترك بخصوص الحرب في
اوكرانيا كررت اغلب دول اذانتها لمواصفته
بالعدوان الروسي بالطبع على روسيا والصين
لكن السيطره الملف على الاجتماعات كان
اقرب للمهزل في نظر وزير الخارجيه روسيس
اما وزير الخارجيه الهندي فسعى لابراز ما
راه ايجابيا مؤكدا ان المجتمعين توافقوا
حول العديد من القضايا
لكن ابرز ما رسظ في الاجتماعات كان لقاء
عابرا بين الوزيرين
سعى خلاله الاخير لتمرير رساله واضحه
لروسيا
بعدوانها على اوكرانيا
اليوم تتباطا روسيا مره اخرى في تصدير
المواد الغذائيه من اوكرانيا ومع انتهاء
الصلاحيه مبادره البحر الاسود رفضت روسيا
الالتزام بتجديدها والرساله التي قالتها
الدول في اجتماع اليوم واضحه لابد من
تمديد مبادره حبوب البحر الاسود وتعزيزا
دون تاخير
اخبرت وزير الخارجيه بما قلته الاسبوع
الماضي في الامم المتحده وبما قاله الكثير
من وزراء خارجيه مجموعه العشرين اليوم قلت
له انه حرب العدوان وانخرطوا في دبلوماسيه
هادفه يمكنها انتاج سلام عادل ودائم
دقائق معدوده جمعت بلينكن بلا برووف وجها
لوجه على هامش محادثات مجموعه العشرين
لقاء هو الاول منذ ازمه اوكرانيا على ارض
الهند محادثه على عجل لم تتجاوز 10 دقائق
اكد فيها بلينكن لنظيره الروسي ان واشنطن
ستواصل دعم كييف عسكريا
وحظ فيها روسيا على الحوار لحل الصراع
والتراجع عن قرارها بتعليق معاهده نيو
ستارت للحد من الاسلحه النوويه قائلا انها
تصب في مصلحه البلدين والامن الدولي
كما استغل بلينكن الفتره الوجيزه ليطلب من
لابروف اطلاق سراح عنصر في البحريه
الامريكيه يدعى
وبحسب المسؤول فان بلينكن اراد نقله تلك
الرساله بعظمه لسانه الخارجيه الروسيه
بدورها اوضحت انهم مجرد تجاذب لاطراف
الحديث ولم تكن هناك مفاوضات والاجتماعات
رسميه
وزير الخارجيه الصينيه خلال الاجتماعات
لتثبيت موقف الصين اذا اكد ان ستحافظ على
الاتصالات والتنسيق مع روسيا على جميع
المستويات كما جدد دعم بلاده لكل الجهود
المبذوله لدفع محادثات السلام واستعدادها
للعب دور بناء في هذا الصدد
من باريس ينضم الينا وزير الخارجيه
الفرنسيه الاسبق
اهلا بك
اليوم هذا الاجتماع خرج من دون بيان ختامي
البعض اعتبر بان روسيا نجحت بما ارادت
وايضا هناك اشخاص او هناك مراقبون يقراون
هذا
هذا الحصل اليوم في هذا الاجتماع بشكل
مغير كيف تقراون ما حصل اليوم
هي مجموعه القاده وبالتالي الاجتماع
الوزاري الاجتماع وزراء الخارجيه هو
اجتماع تحضيري وتكون الامور فيه صعبه
واكثر تعقيد لكنني الاحظ امرين اولهما هو
ان الوزراء تطرقوا الى الوضع في اوكرانيا
لانه يستحيل تجاهل هذا الملف لان بلدا
مستقلا تعرض للغزو من قبل بلد جار
اوكرانيا الحره والمستقيلة غزتها روسيا
وهذا طبعا اثار صدمه كبيره وربما لاحظت
انه في الجمعيه العامه للامم المتحده تمت
قرار تم تبنيه
وقدمته اوكرانيا
وكان الهدف منه هو ايدانه
العدوان الروسي
والمطالبه بانسحاب القوات الروسيه
141 دوله من اصل حوالي 135 دوله
هذا القرار وهذا يعني بان الغالبيه العظمى
لممثلي للدول في الامم المتحده
يرون بالفعل بان روسيا كانت على خطا عندما
غزت اوكرانيا البلد الجار ثانيا عندما
نستمع الى ما يقوله الصينيون فيجب ان ننظر
الى الجوانب التصريحات المختلفه فسين تقول
انها صديقه لروسيا وانا لا اعترض على ذلك
هذا الحق السيادي لكل دوله في اختيار
الاصدقاء والصين
علاقات صداقه في بين
الدول ومع روسيا وانه الاحظ ذلك
ليس الا وهذا لا يثير اي رد الفعل سلبيه
ثم
ينبغي الاطلاع على الموقف الرسمي للحكومه
في الصينيه فيما يتعلق بالازمه الاوكرانيه
فهذا الموقف
المتضمن في 12 نقطه اعلن عنها مؤخرا جلبت
اهتمام الدبلوماسيه في العالم لاسيه ما في
اوروبا وسبب هو ان الصين تقول بعض الامور
السن تقول طبعا تدعم وجهه النظر الروسيه
ولكنها في الوقت ذاته
وكان طبعا هذا من النقاط الاولى في هذا
الموقف اذا هذا صلب التفكير الصيني
الامر يتعلق
بالاولويه او ربما مساله سياده الدول
واحترام هويتها وكذلك استقلالها ارى هذا
التصريح كاملا وهذا يسعدني وارى كيف لي ان
اصف ذلك
ان الصينيين يشعرون بالاحراج لانه من
ناحيه يريدون ان يكونوا اصدقاء في روسيا
ولكنه في الوقت ذاته لا يريدون ما تقوم به
روسيا في اوكرانيا هذا هو الواقع السياسي
الموجود اليوم واتمنى ان تعمل الصين على
مساعدتنا لتسويه هذه الازمه ولكن
هذا تحديدا ما قالته الصين وارى في ذلك
عاملا ايجابيا للغايه نامل
تتمكن الصين من اقناعي روسيا
وعن الرئيس يسعى لاقناع الرئيس بوتين
شخصيا
بضروره والطابع الملح للانسحاب من
اوكرانيا ومن كافه الاراضي الاوكرانيه حتى
يعود السلم باسرع ما يمكن في هذه المنطقه
من العالم والتي تواجه تلاقي الكبرى نعاني
منها نحن الاوروبيون والعالم
اتمنى منك ان تبقى معي لنطلع بعض اكثر على
موضوع اتساع الحرب الروسيه في اوكرانيا
ومن ثم نعود للمتابعه اذا مشاهدينا اتساع
الحرب الروسيه في اوكرانيا ودخولها عامها
الثاني دفع بعض الدول لتغيير وجهه نظرها
بشان ارسال مساعدات عسكريه لاوكرانيا
مثلا قالت ان سويسرا قد تصبح حجره امام
المساعدات المقدمه لاوكرانيا وهو ما سيؤدي
الى حاله من الاحباط في المعسكر الغربي
الداعم لكياب الصحيفه ايضا اضافت ان
الجهود الغربيه اصطدمت بحاجز يعتبر
تقليديا في سويسرا منذ قرون وهو الحياد
فالدوله الواقعه وسط القاره العجوز موطن
لصناعه اسلحه متطوره لكنها في ذات الوقت
تلتزم بمبدا الابتعاد عن الحروب الخارجيه
على الارض يعني هذا ان تقوم سويسرا بحظر
تصدير واعاده تصدير الاسلحه والذخيرا الى
مناطق النزاع كما ذكرنا مشاهدينا الموقف
السويسري هو عائق امام الناتو مثلا على
سبيل المثال الذي تسعى لامداد اوكرانيا
بشكل متواصل بمختلف انواع الاسلحه
والذخيره ويدخل حياد سويسرا لجهود الغربيه
في عنق زجاجه مع الانقطاعات في سلسله
توريد الى اوكرانيا التي تستهلكها بوتيره
اسرع بكثير ما يمكن لشركائها الغربيين
انتاجه بالاضافه لهذه الضغوط الغربيه على
بورد يخطط مشرعون اوكرانيون من لجنه
الشؤون الخارجيه في البرلمان لارسال وفد
خاص لزياره العاصمه السويسريه للمطالبه
بتغيير السياسه اعاقه جهود التصدير اشتكت
منها دول كاسبانيا والدنمارك بعد رفض
سويسرا السماح بتصدير انظمه الدفاع الجوي
سبايدرانا ثلاثه الى اوكرانيا وكلاهما
يحتوي على اجزاء سويسريه الصنع ايضا برلين
كانت ضغطت مرارا على تغيير سياستها بعدما
رفضت الاخيره طلبات الاذن بارسال ذخيره
مصنوعه في سويسرا سبق لالمانيا ان اشترتها
هو يشمل هذا منظومه
التي نشرتها اوكرانيا
[موسيقى]
الانتقادات الموجهه لسويسرا مشاهدينا جاءت
كذلك من امين عام الناتو يانس الشهر
الماضي عندما تحدث عن سويسرا مواربه وقال
انه في حاله اوكرانيا لا يتعلق الامر
بالحياد بل هو مرتبط باحترام الحق في
الدفاع عن النفس وحمايه سياده القانون
والدفاع ايضا عن ميثاق الامم المتحده
بينما قالت رئيسه المفوضيه الاوروبيه
ان الامتناع عن التصويت ليس خيارا لسويسرا
وان على كل الدول ان تختار جانبا تنضم له
جانب القانون او قانون القوه وجانب
الديمقراطيه او الاستبداد على حد قول
فوندرلين نشير هنا سريعا مشاهدينا الى ان
سويسرا تتخذ موقفا يعرف باسم الحياد
المسلح الذي تنظمه المعاهدات الدوليه
والتشريعات المحليه ما يعني ان البلاد
تحتفظ بقوه كبيره لحمايه سيادتها لكنها
تبقى بعيده عن النزاعات الخارجيه لهذا
السويسرا بانه لا يمكن ان يكون هناك تنازل
عن الحياد لانه جزء من نظامها الدستوري
خلال الاسابيع الاولى من حرب اوكرانيا نجح
القاده الاوروبيون والمتظاهرون المحليون
في الضغط على السويسرا للانضمام الى
عقوبات الاتحاد الاوروبي ضد موسكو وهو ما
دعى روسيا الى اضافه سويسرا الى قائمه
الدول غير الصديقه اما في ملف التسليح
اثارت الضغوط من دول مثل المانيا وهي اكبر
مشتري للاسلحه السويسريه والتي هددت
بالغاء عقود طويله الاجل مع شركه سويسريه
نقاشا في البرلمان السويسري حول تعديل
قوانينها للسماح لدول ثالثه محدده باعاده
تصدير الاسلحه والذخيره وفي وقت صاغ فيه
مشرعون السويسريون مجموعه من التعديلات
على القانون المنظم لتجاره الاسلحه الا
انه ليس من الواضح ما اذا كان بالامكان
حشده الاغلبيه في البرلمان حتى وان تم
[موسيقى]
الى الجانب الاخر الان من المعادله مجله
نيوزويك نشرت تقريرا اعتبرت فيه ان المجر
وعبر رئيس وزرائها قد تشكل بمواقفها بسيطه
امل لبوتين في ازمه اوكرانيا الحديث هنا
عن الناتو والعضوين الجديدين المفترضين
فنلندا والسويد والانضمام للحلف لابد ان
توافق برلمانات الدول الاعضاء على ضم
الدولتين وباجماع 30 دوله وفي العاصمه اجل
البرلمان المجري مره اخرى التصويت على
انضمام فنلندا والسويد للنيتو رئيس
الوزراء المجري اتخذ خلال فتره توليه
السلطه خطابا متمردا على الاجماع الاوروبي
كما كانت له مواقف متعاطفه مع موسكو اضافه
لتعطيل عقوبات الاتحاد الاوروبي ويوم
الثامن عشر من الشهر الماضي خلال خطابه عن
حالات الامه اعتبر اوربن ان الغرب لم يعزل
الصراع في اوكرانيا فقط بل نشره الى عموم
قاره اوروبا مضيفا ان حلفاء اوكرانيا
تعهد خلال كلمته بالحفاظ على العلاقات مع
روسيا كما طالبت دول الاوروبيه بالشيء
نفسه لانه دون علاقات بحسب اوربين لن يكون
هناك وقف اطلاق النار ولا محادثات سلام
التقت خبراء في الشؤون المجاريه وقالوا ان
مشاكسات قرب مع الناتو والاتحاد الاوروبي
جزء من القتال بين بروكسل كما انها من
جانب اخر قد تكون محاوله لشراء رداء روسيا
التي تعد واحده من اكبر موردي الطاقه في
المجر اضاف الخبراء ان خطاب رئيس وزراء
المجر هو موجه بشكل اكبر للداخل خاصه في
الملف الاوكراني لكنه عاده ما يسقط
تهديدات الفيتو في اللحظه الاخيره نظرا
لاعتماد المجر الاقتصادي على الاتحاد
الاوروبي ولان اوربن يعرف من يدفع فواتير
المجر ودائما بحسب التقرير
يحاول الاوكرانيون اقناع اوروبا بان روسيا
لن تتوقف حتى المحيط الاطلسي لكن المجريين
لا يقتنعون بهذه التهديدات العالم كله راى
ان الجيش الروسي ليس في وضع يسمح له
بمهاجمه النيتو ولن يكون كذلك لبعض الوقت
مره جديده اعود الى ضيفي في باريس وزير
الخارجيه الفرنسيه الاسبق سيد دوشارات
هناك انقسام الى حد ما تجاه اوكرانيا من
الدول الاوروبيه هل هذا الامر سيعقد الامر
اكثر ام من الممكن ان نرى مبادره جديده من
قبل اوروبا لانهاء هذه الازمه وهذه الحرب
في اوكرانيا
بدايه
انا تابعت
[موسيقى]
وذكرتموه قبل قليل وانا اعرف التعقيدات
المشريه وكما ذكرتم بدقه كبيره الجميع
يدرك من يدفع فواتير المجر فهي والاتحاد
الاوروبي بعباره اخرى اعتقد ان الحاله
المجريه سوف تجد طريقها الى الحل حتى وان
كان السيد فيكتور اوربان يسعى
ربما
الابتسام في وجه السيد بوتين هذه ليست
بالاحداث المهمه جدا وسنتمكن من حل هذه
المشكله ولكن
بالنسبه لسويسرا فهي بلد على الحياد ولا
يمكن ان تبيع اسلحه يمكن استخدامها
طبعا هذا هذا الموقف جدير بالاهتمام وكما
تلاحظين منذ البدايه قلنا ان الاوروبيين
سوف ينقسمون على انفسهم كما جرت العاده
ولن يتفقوا ولكن التجربه اثبتت العكس
تماما فالاوروبيون باستثناء المجر التي
يتبنت مواقف مختلفه الى حد ما البلدان
الاوروبيه 27 اظهرت عزمها وسرامتها ووضوح
رؤيتها سياسيه
واعتقد ان هذا عنصر سياسي حاسم وانه من
الاهميه بما كان ان على الجميع ان يدرك
ذلك سواء كان في موسكو او في بيجي شكرا لك
من باريس وزير الخارجيه الفرنسيه الاسبق
على المشاركه معنا في 360
اكدت خدمه الامن الروسيه اف اس بي ان
الوضع في منطقه بيريانس قرب الحدود مع
اوكرانيا تحت السيطره وكان الرئيس فلاديمي
بوتين اتهم مخربين اوكرانيين بتنفيذ عمليه
ارهابيه في المنطقه وقال انهم استهدفوا
مدنيين وهو ما اعتبرته باستفزازا كاذبا
الحرب مواجهه مفتوحه احيانا تتجاوز ظروف
الزمن والمكان من شرق اوكرانيا الى غرب
روسيا تستمر الاحداث المتسارعه حدث مقاطعه
داخل التراب الروسي قد يغير المعادله
ويفتح جبهه جديده المخابره الاوكرانيه
قالت ان الهجوم نفذه معارضون من الداخل ضد
نظام بوتين ويريدون القضاء عليه الرئيس
الروسي الذي الغى رحلته التي كانت مخططا
لها الى
الهجوم بالارهابي
اليوم نفذوا هجوما ارهابيا اخر نفذوا
جريمه اخرى على منطقه حدوديه وفتحوا النار
على مدنيين رغم رؤيتهم بان السياره مدنيه
ويجلس فيها مدنيون واطفاله هؤلاء الاشخاص
اخذوا على عاتقهم مهمه انتزاع ذاكرتنا
وتاريخنا وعاداتنا وحتى لغتنا ورغم ان
المجموعه التي نفذت الهجوم نشرت مقطعا
مصورا لعناصرها داخل المقاطعه و هم يرفعون
شعار الجيش الاوكراني قال مستشار الرئاسه
الاوكرانيه
ان الهجوم مفبرك ومزيف الى ذلك تبنت
المجموعه التي اغتالت ابنه المفكر الروسي
المقرب من الكرملين الكسندر دوغان الهجمه
فيبريانس تطور جديد قد يغير مسار الحرب
رغم ان كي اف تنفيصلتها بالموضوع خلال
الوجدتين العربيه
منضم الى مراسل العربيه حذيفه عادل من
موسكو ينضم الينا ايضا عبد الجواد الرشده
اهلا بكما حذيفه سابدا معك بالنسبه كيف او
ما هي الروايه بالنسبه للجانب الاوكراني
اتجاه ما حصل في بيريان
مساء الخير
في الحقيقه رد الفعل الاول اتى من القياده
العملياتيه الشماليه للقوات المسلحه
الاوكرانيه التي بادرت وقالت ان ما تم في
برياسك هو
عفوا هو امر ملفق ومزور تماما وان الاتحاد
الروسي يحاول من خلاله تشويه سمعه الجيش
الاوكراني وبالمناسبه طبعا القياده
العملياتيه الشماليه كانت قد اعلنت في
الثالث والعشرين من فبراير ان سوف تكون
هنالك عمليات استزازيه في برياس تحديدا
وانها رصدت معلومات حول هذا الامر وتتوقع
ان يحدث في الغريب ولتشويس سرعه الجيش
الاوكراني بعد ذلك طبعا ميخائيل بودلاك
واستشاره الرئيسكي كان قد تحدث حول هذا
الامر وقال ان هذه هي روسيا الكلاسيكيه
وان الامر ملفق تماما وقال ايضا ان
الاتحاد وقال انه هنالك اكثر من سيناريو
لهذا الامر ولكن في البث تحدث عن ان
الاتحاد الروسي يزور مثل هذه الامور اولا
يعني
بين مواطنيه وايضا لتبرير الفقر الذي
يعيشون فيه بسبب الحرب ولكن ايضا هنالك
سيناريوهين اما ان تكون هذا هو الفيلق هو
فيلق للقوات لبعض المتطوعين الروس الذين
يساندون اوكرانيا وفي ذات الوقت هم
يحاولون تدمير نظام بوتين من الداخل وهذا
السيناريو الثاني هو ان هذا الامر يعني
يتم عن طريق تزوير من قبل الاتحاد الروسي
لاتهام اوكرانيا وايضا قال انه لا يوجد
لدينا حاجه في اوكرانيا لعمليات استفزازيه
مع الاتحاد الروسي خاصه واننا في حاله حرب
فعليا بشكل حقيقي بيننا وبين الاتحاد
الروسي لذلك نفع اي صله للجانب الاوكراني
لارسال مثل هذه المجموعات وان هذه
المجموعات تم اعقد اعلنت عن نفسها بعد ذلك
ايضا جارت الفعل من الاستخبارات العسكريه
الاوكرانيه على لسان اندريه يوسف وهو
الناطق الرسمي باسم الاستخبارات العسكريه
وقال انه تم الاعلان من قبل
من كون هذه المجموعه ووصفوا نفسهم
فيلق المتطوعين الروس
واهدافهم هي ان يساندوا الجيش الاوكراني
وكذلك هو طبعا انهم غير راضيين عن الوضع
في الداخل وانهم سوف يقومون بحركه مقاومه
داخليه بالمناسبه هنالك ايضا اليوم مجموعه
اخرى تكونت في شيء في جزيره القرم واعلنت
عن نفسها تسمي نفسها اتاش وهي مجموعه ايضا
تساند القوات المسلحه الاوكرانيه وتقول
انها في انتظار القوات المسلحه الاوكرانيه
حتى تعبر الحدود واعلنت عن ان لديها اسلحه
ولديها متفجرات وانها قامت بتوزيع هذه
الاسلحه والمتفجرات وانها سوف تقوم بتلغيم
السكه الحديد وايضا قالت ان لديها اكثر من
4000 شخص تم تدريبهم على مستوى عالي دعنا
نذهب الى زميلنا عبد الجواد الرشد من
موسكو لنعرف منه ايضا الموقف الروسي تج
اه هذها ما مدى
وما هي الاجراء
ات اتخذ بعد هذه العمليه عبد الجواد ماذا
لدينا
مساء الخير ميسون لك ولحذيفه نعم في
الحقيقه الامن الفيدرالي الروسي يتحدث عن
سيطره كامله في الوقت الحالي على بريانسك
المحاذيه للاراضي الاوكرانيه وللشريط
الحدودي طبعا هذه العمليه التي جرت اليوم
لا يمكن اخفاء قلق القياده الروسيه من
حولها لكن طبعا موسكو اصبحت تتحدث بشكل
رسمي عن ضروره الاستعداد للاسوء كما نلاحظ
خلال الايام الاخيره الماضيه طالت العديد
من المسيرات الاوكرانيه العمق الروسي
ووصلت الى بعد حوالي 100 كم من العاصمه
الروسيه موسكو طبعا الشريط الحدودي بين
روسيا واوكرانيا ميسون ليس هي المره
الاولى التي يتعرض لضربات اوكرانيا لكن
الفارق الوحيد اليوم هو عمليه التسلل التي
ادت الى احداث مشكله كبيره طبعا والحديث
دار عنها كثيرا في الاوساط الروسيه ولد
قراءه ولد قراء السياسه
وما يحدث في الاوضاع العسكريه في الاراضي
الاوكرانيه من جهه اخرى لذلك طبعا نلاحظ
بان نائب رئيس مجلس الامن الروسي خرج قبل
نصف ساعه من الان وهو الرئيس السابق
لروسيا وتحدث عن هذا الموضوع وقد يعني حمل
واشنطن والغرب والعواصم الاوروبيه مسؤوليه
ما يحدث ووصفهم بداعمي الارهاب حسب قوله
طبعا
بتصريحات ناريه كما عود متابعي خلال
الاونه الاخيره على تيليجرام وتحدث عن انه
من سيقوم بتخديم الطائرات العسكريه التي
ستسلم لاوكرانيا في بولندا خلال الفتره
القادمه يعني سيكون مشاركا في الحرب ضد
روسيا وهو طبعا يتحدث عن دول الناتو وايضا
تحدث عن ان موسكو ستعتبر من سيقوم بتقديم
هذه الطائرات اهدافا عسكريه لها لذلك طبعا
نلاحظ بان موسكو اصبحت على ثقه بان الجانب
الاوكراني سيحصل على مقاتلات في القريب
العاجل وهذا طبعا ما سيؤدي الى تصعيد موقف
من جهه وزياده الصراع من جهه اخرى خاصه مع
احتدام العمليات العسكريه في جنوب في ضخم
والتحديدا اليوم على ما يبدو ان هذه
المعركه حسب القراءه الروسيه العسكريه
بدات تحسم بشكل كبير لصالح قوات فاجنر وهي
ايام معدوده كما يتحدث الجانب
وسيتم الاعلان عن سيطره على هذه المدينه
اشكركما من موسكو عبد الجواد الرشته وايضا
حذيفه عادل من كاز على كل هذه المعلومات
والتفاصيل
[موسيقى]
في العربيه 360 سنتابع بعد لحظات
العفو الدوليه تندد باعدامات ايران ابناء
الاقليات وتقول ان المحاكمات جائره
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد كشفت منظمه العفو
الدوليه عن اعدام السلطات الايرانيه الى
ما لا يقل عن 14 كرديا بالاضافه الى 13 من
اقليه البلوش وشخصا من عرب الاحوال بعد
محاكمه وصفتها المنظمه بالجائره منذ بدايه
العام الجاري المنظمه اضافت ايضا ان
السلطات اصدرت ما لا يقل عن 12 حكما
بالاعدام على اشخاص اخرين في تصعيد مخيف
مشيره لاعدام 94 شخصا على الاقل خلال
يناير وفبراير وسط تقارير عن تعذيب
واعتداءات على المعتقلين
[موسيقى]
اعجبت الخارجيه الفرنسيه عن قلقها من
مستويات التخصيب اليورانيوم في ايران
واكدت ان ما كشفته الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه
مؤخرا حول جزيئات تيرانيوم يقترب تخصيبها
من 90% مقلق للغايه وغير مسبوق
وفي الاثناء كشفت صحيفه الامريكيه عن
انقسام في الرائي بين امريكا واوروبا بشان
الرد على تخصيب ايران اليورينيوم كما اكدت
على ان دبلوماسيين اوروبيين يرون ان خطوات
ايران سبب كاف لالغاء اتفاق 2015 نهائيا
وان دول اوروبيه تريد لوم ايران رسميا في
اجتماعي محافظي الوكاله الذريه المقبل لكن
واشنطن تريد رؤيه تقرير الوكاله الذريه
النهائي قبل لوم ايران رسميا
نبقى مع الشان الايراني فقد تحصل موقع
ايران انترناشونال على رسائل سريه من
وزاره الخارجيه الايرانيه تظهر التشددا من
البنك التجاري العراقي فيما يتعلق بسحب
الاموال الايرانيه المحجوبه ووفقا لتلك
الرسائل السريه فان المصرف التجاريه
العراقي ليس على استعدادا لتنفيذ معاملات
بالمليارات يطلبها الجانب الايراني وانه
على استعداد فقط للافراج عن موارد ايران
في الحالات الانسانيه وبكميات قليله
وبقيود مشدده ايضا وباشراف كامل من وزاره
الخزانه الامريكيه رئيس البنك التجاري
العراقي بلال الحمداني اشار بحسب ايران
انترناشونال الى ان عقب التصاريح
الامريكيه في هذا المجال قائلا انه ليس
فقط من الضروري الحصول على تصريح من وزاره
الخزانه الامريكيه لدفع ثمن المواد
الانسانيه وانما يجب الحصول على تصريح
لبنود اخرى وانه يتعين على ايران ارس
مشاهدات ووثائق تحدد البضائع الانسانيه
التي تم شرائها وبخصوص طلب ايران نقل اصول
بقيمه مليون دولار لشركه مبنى مختصه بمجال
الطاقه اكد رئيس البنك التجاري العراقي
انه بسبب المعاملات المشبوهه فقد صدر
تعميم ضد شركه مبنى ولا يمكن تلبيه طلب
الجانب الايراني في هذا الصدد ويتساءل
البنك التجاري العراقي عن البنك الذي
ستودع فيه المبالغ باعتبار ان البنك
المركزي الايراني تحت عقوبات من قبل
الولايات المتحده وكشفت التجاري والعراقي
ايضا عن عدم وجود تخطيط او تنسيق في حكومه
ابراهيم رئيسي لتوفير العمله للسلع
الاساسيه من الاموال الايرانيه المحجوبه
في العراق
من لندن ينضم اليه صادق الركابي مدير
المركز العالمي للدراسات التنمويه سيد
الركابي اهلا بك معنا هذه المراسلات تكشف
بانه الحكومه العراقيه ملتزمه بضوابط
امريكا كيف سيؤثر هذا الالتزام من قبل
العراق على اقتصاد ايران
نعم تحياتي لكم من الواضح ان ايران كانت
مستفيده بشكل كبير من التساؤل الذي كان
يتم لمنحها العمله الصعبه او عمليات
الشراء التي تتم عن طريق اموال توضع في
حسابات عن طريق المصرف العراقي للتجاره
لصالح ايران الان المشكله ان الرقابه من
قبل الخزانه الامريكيه بدات تؤثر بشكل
كبير على تدفق السلع الى ايران هناك قرابه
سلع بقرابه مليارين وسبعمائه مليون دولار
الان موجوده تنتظر التفريغ على الموانع
الايرانيه ولا يوجد عمله صعبه لتدفع
للتجار حتى يفرغوها وبالتالي هذا يشكل خطر
على تواجد هذه السلع وارتفاع في التضخم
الان هناك ارتفاع كبير في اسعار السلع في
ايران وانهيار كبير في قيمه العمله
الايرانيه وبالتالي التدقيق والتشديد الذي
حصل في العراق السنه بشكل مباشر على
الاقتصاد ايراني وعلى حاله المواطنين في
ايران طيب السؤال الان هل
سيستفيد العراق من التزامه مع الخزانه
الامريكيه ام سيلحق ضرر كبير بالعراق من
غضب ايران منه
يعني صحيح هناك خشيه الان من ان يتم
استخدام ملف الغاز في ايران وقطع الغاز عن
العراق لان العراق يعتمد بقرابه 40% في
استيراد الغاز على ايران بالنسبه لتوليد
الكهرباء وهناك خشيه من ان لا يكون هناك
اطلاق لكميات من الغاز خلال الصيف ويتم
استخدام هذا الامر لاثاره الشارع العراقي
ولكن بالنسبه للاقتصاد عراقي هو استفاد
الان بشكل كبير من تدقيق الخزانه
الامريكيه لانك كميه الدولارات التي كانت
تهرب عن طريق الفواتير المزوره بحجه
استيراد صلع الان هذه الكميات تضاءلت بشكل
كبير وهذه الاموال اذا ما استخدمت بشكل
افضل تستخدم داخل اقتصاد عراقي في عمليات
التنميه فبالتالي هو هناك استفاده لاقتصاد
عراقي ولكن هناك خشيه من ان يتم الضغط
الايراني الكبير حتى على حاله الاستقرار
في الشارع العراقي
في زياره سيد غوتيرش الى العراق حقيقه
اشاد باداء الحكومه العراقيه هل هذا مثلا
يمكن ان يفتح ابواب جديده للعراق
لتستفيد من هذه
الرؤيه تجاه هذه الحكومه او هذه المواقف
تجاه هذه الحكومه وهذه الاشاده
يعني حتى بالنسبه للجانب الايراني لا يوجد
خيار امام الجانب الايراني الا اللي
نصيحه الحكومه السوداني بمسايره الامريكان
فيما يريدونه لانه هناك تهديدات صريحه
صدرت من الخزان الامريكيه لحكومه السودان
بانه عليكم الالتزام بضوابط الخزانه
الامريكيه وبالضوابط المفروضه من ناحيه
عدم تهريب العمله والا سوف يتم قطع النظام
المالي المصرفي العراقي عن النظام العالمي
وهذا الامر جعل حكومه السودان الان تدرك
جديه هذا الامر وتعمل على بالفعل ان
تستخدم اموال العراق التي كانت تهرب في
الخارج في عمليات التنميه لانه لا مفر
امام هذه الحكومه الا بالانصياع الى رغبه
شعبها الذي عانى بشكل كبير خلال الفترات
الماضيه وهي تقول بان حكومه خدمات ونامل
بانها ان تنفذ فعلا برنامجها الذي يعني هو
لخدمه الصالح العراقي والع راق اختصاد
وطني شكرا لك من لندن صادق الركابي مدير
المركز العالمي للدراسات التنمويه
[موسيقى]
حقبه قوانين تنظيم داعش المتشدده وحكمه
القائم على الترهيب لن تنتهي بعد العربيه
هو ضمن تغطيتها الخاصه تمكنت من دخول مخيم
روج الذي تقيم فيه عوائل وعناصر ومقاتلي
داعش الاوروبيين تهديدات مبطنه وعلنيه
قلبت احوال المخيم الذي بدا بترويج صوره
مختلفه للداعشيات اللواتي خلعنا نقابهن
لكن الصوره تبدو اسوا واخطر في مخيم الهول
الذي تحولت اقسام منه لمراكز تعذيب وقتل
حيث شهد العام الماضي مقتل 36 شخصا على
ايدي خلايا التنظيم فيما يبرز دور اهم دور
اهم للداعشيات في تنسيق العمليات الهجوميه
داخل المخيم وايضا خارجه
[موسيقى]
نتفاوض معها للحديث بعد ان تملكها ارتياب
وتردد
قبل سنه فقط كانت كاساندر داعشيه
البلجيكيه وزوجه احد قاده التنظيم
المقتولين في الرقه تتحدث بثقه مع العربيه
عن قصتها كاول امراه تخلع النقاب في مخيم
روش
[موسيقى]
هيئتها تغيرت وقبضه خلايا التنظيم اشتدت
وان امتنعت عن تفسير تحولها هذا
مختلف
بس يعني مختلف من بره بس من جوا ما غير
شيء يعني
ماذا تقول ما
بدي نحكي من هذا
كانت رؤيه الكثيرات يتجولن دون غطاء راس
ممكنه هناك لكن اليوم ثلاث فقط بقينا دون
حجاب او نقاب ريان واحده منهن تقول انها
تعرضت للتهديد وعرضوا عليها اموالا
[موسيقى]
من مخيم روج انتقل الى الهول الاخطر على
الاطلاق
المواجهه الامنيه مع تنظيم داعش كانت اكثر
حصما ووضوحا لكن مواجهه فكره وارثه معركه
اخرى لم تحسم بعد هنا في مخيم الهول في
الحسكه نسخه متجدده عن تنظيم داعش اصغر
ولكنها ليست اقل تطرفا فلتنظيم هنا ممولون
خلايا التجنيد والتدريب كما له قوانينه
ومحاكم
الحسابات مختلفه هنا وكلها تخضع لقوانين
داعش ترهيب التزم بقوانين التنظيم واحرق
خيانهن او ايذاءهن جسديا هذه الصور كافيه
لشرح ما يحدث اربع نساء احتجزهن التنظيم
وقيدهم بالسلاسل في مركز تعذيب اقيم سرا
داخل مخيم الهول
[موسيقى]
لا تتوقفوا نساء داعش عند التعذيب العام
الماضي شهد المخيم مقتل 36 شخصا بينه
فتاتان مصريتان اكتشفت جثتهما في مجاري
الصرف الصحي حوادث كشفت عن دور المحوري
للنساء داخل خلايا التنظيم بينها تهريب
السلاحه
[موسيقى]
اسمه محمد احمد طلب مني اجيب له من محل
ابو عمار خلاط مال الفواكه
رحت جبتليهم بعد ما وصلته
فتحت ترمز طالع منه مسدس بعد ما طالع
المسدس قال لي
تودينا مكان شخص
اخذتها المسدس وراحت وديته على الشخص اسمه
نور بعد فتره تم توقيفي من قضى الجهاز امن
العام
لم يقتصر نشاط نساء داعش داخل حدود مخيم
الهول فالتحقيقات كشفت ايضا انهن حلقه وصل
رئيسيه لتنسيق هجمات التنظيم
حمله التمشيط الاخيره حتى الهجوم على سجن
صناعه
المعلومات لدينا انه الذ
الشخص الذي كان يقوم با يعني الاتصال ما
بين السجن وخارج السجن كانت امراه من ضمن
المخيم
وضعت في الفتره الاخيره يعتمد على النساء
اكثر يقومون باخفاء الاسلحه الذخيره
او المنشورات
ويتحركون بشكل افضل
حتى عن طريق الانترنت يقوم بالتواصل
ارسلت تعليمات من والى ضعف
في مخيم الهول قصه لا تنتهي هذا قسم
مستحدث يسمونه المنطقه الامنه ينقل اليه
من يثبت ان حياته في خطر بسبب تهديد خلايا
داعشه
[موسيقى]
جنب مسجد
الثاني ولمن يضربوا حدا
الرصاص نسمع صوت الرصاص يجيبوني مثلا صلاه
الفجر مشان الناس
تنفذ امام المسجد يعني بعيد شويه يعني
الخطر يبقى قائما في مخيم تنشط فيه خلايا
داعش وتسعى لكسر قيود الاحتجاز واعاده
تنظيم صفوفها ساره بنعيشوبا العربيه من
شمال شرق سوريا
[موسيقى]
في تركيا وضمن الانتقادات المساره حول
كارثه انهيار المباني ما تزال مدينه ارزين
الصغيره قرب هاتاي تثير الكثير من الحيره
لماذا هذه المدينه التي يبلغ عدد سكانها
42 الف نسمه لم تسجل اي انهيارات للمباني
او اصابات رغم الماسات التي شهدتها ما
حولها من مدن السر كما يقول اوكي السائل
مازوكلو عمده المدينه هو الالتزام الصارم
بقوانين البناء وابلاغ النيابه عن
المخالفين ويشرح ان المباني لديه بين
طابقين واربعه مع مبنى واحد من سته طوابق
وانه رفض الضغوطا للقبول بالاستثناءات
وجاء السادس من فبراير ليثبت وجهه نظر
العمده الشاب بعد ان منيت المدن من حوله
بعشرات الاف الوفيات بينما باتت عشرات
الاف المباني تحت قيد الهدم الاجباري
المفارقه ان العمده خسر الكثير من تاييد
قبل الزلزال بسبب صرامته في موضوع البناء
والان يتلقى الكثير من النقد بسبب حديثه
عن عدم وجود ضحايا في مدينته اذ غابت عنه
المساعدات الحكوميه بعد زلزال لم يعجب هذا
الامر البعض ممن طروا للمبيت في الخيام
خوفا من العوده لمنازلهم المتصدعه
ورسالتهم له عدم موتنا في الزلزال لا يعني
انه ليس لدينا احتياجات
واليوم صوت البرلمان التركي بالاجماع على
انشاء لجنه برلمانيه لتحقيق في التداعيات
التي نجمت عن الزلزال ياتي هذا بينما قدرت
تقارير حجم الحطام بنحو 210 ملايين طن ما
قد يغطي 100 كيلومتر مربع بارتفاع 100 متر
وهي مساحه تعادل مساحه مدينه برشلونه
الاسبانيه
في العربيه 360 حادث كبير ارق الدنماركيين
حوريه البحر الشهيره في كوبنهاجن غيرت
هويتها وصارت روسيه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد في مقابله خاصه مع
العربيه شدد رئيس الحكومه الليبيه المكلف
المجلس النواب فتحي بشاغه على ان حكومته
اكتسبت شرعيتها من مجلسين نواب والدوله في
المقابل قال ان حكومه دبيبه هي مؤقته
ومحدده المده بالسنه وان البرلمان سحب ثقه
منها
حكوميه تحصلت على منح الثقه من مجلس
النواب وايضا اناك رئيس وزراء وتبع هذا
الاجراء اجراء قبل يعني كان فيه اجراء من
مجلس الدوله
ان المجلس الدوله اذا 53 عضو وهو كما ورد
في الاتفاق السياسي الليبي اللي تم توقيع
بسنه 2015 ربما يعتقد العديد من الليبيين
ولا غير الليبيين انه هو تم منعي من
الحكومه الولايه او من المجموعات المسلحه
ولكن هذا غير صحيح
الامم المتحده لم تعترف بالخطوه لقام بها
مجلس الدوله
والبرلمان
واعترفت في البدايه كرئيس وزراء ولكنها لم
تعترف بالحكومه وشككت في مصداقيه التصويت
مع انه هو تم تسجيله بالكامل يعني بالصوت
والصوره من ناحيه الشرعيه لم يقويه لانه
هو تم سحب اولا الاتفاق اللي تم في جنيف
هي هذه الحكومه مدتها سنه تقود ليبيا
للانتخابات وتنتهي في شهر 12
واقصى مده لها كوعاء زمني بعد اجراء بعد
البدءات الانتخابات هو شهر سته حتى يتم
تسليم والاستلام ما بين البرلمان القديم
والجديد وايضا
انتخاب الرئيس وانت الرئيس بانتخب رئيس
وزراء هذه كلها تحتاج الى حوالي اربعه الى
سته اشهر ولكن ايضا انتهت شرعيته
والبرلمان سحب من الثقه
في تغطيه خاصه تبدا من العشره صباحا
بتوقيت السعوديه السابع بتوقيت جرينتش
تحتفل العربيه بالذكرى العشرين الانطلقتها
في الثالث من مارس لعام 2003 باقه متنوعه
من النشرات
ستتابعونها غدا
مشاهدينا وسنكون معكم في يوم مطول
للاحتفال بالعشرين عاما للعربيه وطبعا كل
عام والعربيه والمشاهدين بالف خير
[موسيقى]
فيديو اليوم من تركيا ثلاثه اسابيع فصلت
بين الجدي وحفيدته بعد ان يتشلهما رجال
الانقاذ من تحت انقاضها التعيه ولج الجد
في مدينته بينما ارسلت الحفيده الى مشفى
على بعد مئات الكيلومترات
اضطر الجد للانتظار كل هذه المده حتى تثبت
اختبارات الحمض النووي انهما فقط من تبقى
احياء من العائله لم يتمالك الجد دموعه في
لحظه اللقاء
فالصغيره بالنسبه له هي كل ما تبقى من
الماضي وبالنسبه لها هو كل بشائر المستقبل
ان صوره اليوم من الدنمارك فقد استيقظ
سكان كوبنهاجن على مشهد مثير تمثال حوريه
البحر الشهير في ميناء كوبنهاجن ملون بلون
العلم الروسي
استهدفت التمثال مرارا على مر تاريخه قطعت
ذراعه مره وراسه مرات لكن هذا الحدث لا
يمكن ان تسامح فيه الدنمارك فهو رساله
تضامن مع روسيا غير مسموح بها في ظل الحرب
في اوكرانيا
الى هنا تنتهي ملفات 360 وانما اخبار
العربيه ما زالت مستمره والان مع اخبار
الساعه ومجددا مع صهيب تفضل صهيب ماذا
لدينا الليله مساء الخير ميسون لدينا ابرز
اخبار هذا اليوم طبعا في الصدارتها اللقاء
الاول بين وزير الخارجيه امريكا
وروسيا في نيودلهي على هامش الاجتماع
وزراء خارجيه مجموعه العشرين